pauvre Donny tout va bien non pas vraiment
mon enfant a besoin d'un appareil dentaire ma voiture a
besoin d'un travail de transmission ma femme veut que
je l'emmène en Floride mais je suis en retard
sur les paiements hypothécaires mon oncle a appelé
d'Inde et il a besoin d'argent pour ma
nièce  mariage et j'ai eu cette étrange
éruption cutanée sur le dos et toi je vais bien
quand tu es un enfant tu as appris qu'il
y a trois dimensions hauteur largeur et
profondeur
comme une boîte à chaussures puis plus tard tu entends qu'il y a
une quatrième dimension temps ta poésie est
vraiment très bonne  et un jour tu pourrais
juste décider de laisser le monde le lire
me regarder dans les yeux une seconde
crois-moi bien
tu es un grand poète tu sais que c'est le
bulldog anglais n'aime pas papa
Jack yummy like dog Jack my G dog  Jack
ou me donne quelque chose à attendre avec impatience
que je suppose que je travaille sur un poème pour toi
J'aime m'amuser ouais je suppose que si c'est pour toi
c'est un poème d'amour J'ai eu une idée de Trey
ouais les
bonnes garnitures sont meilleures si vous êtes juste un
chauffeur de bus
ce bus Patterson 23 je ha  Dans une situation,
personne ne bouge et que feriez-vous, vous
aimez quelqu'un et elle dit qu'elle ne
vous veut pas mieux, vous devriez être un
acteur Je suis un acteur
Je
suppose que c'est ton boulet humain et ta
chaîne qui frappe à droite
bonjour chérie oh chérie je peins
bonjour Marvin je vois qu'est-ce que tu
penses ne rend pas tout plus
intéressant ouais c'est très intéressant
comment était ta journée qui
te faisait rouler d'habitude  J'ai fait un petit
ouais en travaillant sur un poème pour toi,
je suppose que si c'est pour toi, c'est un
poème d'amour, il est en quelque sorte inspiré par nos
matchs à pointe bleue de l'Ohio, est-ce que cela mentionne vraiment
la forme du petit mégaphone que les lettres
font ouais en fait ça fait comment  magnifique
j'ai hâte de manger c'est fait j'ai aussi
peint de nouveaux rideaux de douche tu devrais les
voir d'accord tu sais ce que j'ai fait d'autre
aujourd'hui tu as planté un
potager insolite dans la cour arrière idiot
que tu dois faire au printemps
Oh
toi